somebody who is doing uh great stuff for
the los angeles chargers right here
just up the road from us uh the the rare
uh western colorado to nfl path taken by
one austin eckler here on the rich
island show how are you austin
hey what's going on rich i appreciate
you having me on i appreciate you coming
on here
so let's talk about your journey sir um
born in nebraska right born in lincoln
but you
wound up living in colorado is that
correct austin
yeah right uh born in nebraska like you
said and then went
through k through 12 uh out in colorado
in a little farm town called eaton
colorado
okay and so how did you wind up in
western
colorado and how did you get noticed
there austin
um no i wasn't really heavily recruited
out of uh
high school if really recruited at all
by any d1
and so i was looking around the area and
there was division two school
and then at the time it was western
state called the university but they
could
change their name recently you know
there's a couple other d2s that were
reaching out to me but western wanted me
to play running back and that's what i
wanted to play and so
that's why i chose going to western
state and then
your undrafted experience what was draft
day like for you
2017 austin what was that like right so
you know coming from a smaller school um
you know teams think they can pick you
up in uh you know the
the undrafted you know period and so
they don't waste a draft take on you and
so
it was actually better for me because i
was able to kind of pick and choose from
a couple different teams
and the chargers were on the top of my
list i'm in green bay
and and the chargers ended up uh you
know calling me halfway through the
seventh round saying hey if uh
if he doesn't get picked up in his last
few picks and we're
willing to take him on as a drafter free
agent and so from then on
i knew i was probably going through the
chargers did you make it to did you try
to make it to the combine did you
send like dvds around or anything like
that to try and get to the comments
i don't know about dvds let me pass that
time
but excuse me mr eckler mr twitch mr
gamer i
i all right i still get i still get dvds
sent to me at nfl network from people
saying uh can you help me get this in
the hands of somebody
for the combine these these things
happen all right okay i'm not
that old austin i got to push back here
a little bit here
all right i'm very i feel you dvds
laughing at me did you try to get to the
cup
did you try to get to the combine did
you try i
i didn't really try just because i
didn't really have any traction as far
as like i didn't go to senior bowl or
any of the
uh like the higher bowl games
um and so i was like hey let me just try
to get into a pro day because i couldn't
have a product at my school because
if you didn't know western's at 7 800
feet so there's snow
year round during the winter and then
going into spring
so i had to go to cu denver uh calling a
boulder to get there
um to do my pro day there damn
so yeah that's um so were the chargers
there
i mean is that where they first saw you
yeah i mean
so it was kind of uh it's kind of
different so cu
they had their uh pro day with all their
guys and then they had like
add-ons at the end and then there's like
20 of us like from smaller schools
around and just people just trying out
and they let us run 40s and they let us
do our like jumping
measurements and they cut us all down to
two it was me in this other corner
and they told everyone else yeah you're
done you didn't pass it and i was like
oh
like it's already cut through and so
then i went on with the rest of my
protein did some drills
and yeah the chargers were there i think
there was like 20 teams ended up staying
and so i got i put out a pretty good
outing just to
kind of solidify that yeah i have good
numbers um
as far as like measurable and then it
was just all up from there
austin eckler here on the rich eisen
show so
um when you're balling out right now um
what do you think of of those old days i
mean what if you told that kid
that uh needed to go somewhere else for
a pro day and watch draft day
go without him and getting a call from
the charger seventh round and
all of that right what do you think of i
don't you know i don't think i've told
that kid anything but i think that kid
keeps telling me stuff
what is that my current day and that's
just to continue to work and continue to
be efficient
that's kind of what i've that's what my
mind has been
since day one is okay how can i be
efficient with
the opportunities that i have because in
the very beginning of my career my
opportunities were like four plays of
practice
and a couple of those plays would be on
scout team and so it was very very
limited but i wanted to make sure i
studied as much as i could and i knew my
entire job i knew what i had to do so
when i go out there i could play 100
and you know i started to gain traction
because
i remember a specific instance when i
was running down on scout team punt
and we're giving our punt return team a
look and i was running as
fast as i could and it was a hundred
percent we were going full speed
and nobody could block me i made my mind
out nobody could block me
and they came back to film and coach
lynn our head coach walks in the room
and he asks our special teams quote and
he's like hey who's that number three
because at the time award number three
when she came running where's the
running back
so it's basically a long shot from the
beginning so who's number three and
coach stewart special teams coach goes
yeah that's awesome necklace man he's
been giving us great looks out there
and you know so i started to see some
like confirmation like hey i'm being
noticed
and i kept building on that and building
on that until i finally just forced my
way in
into the organization and now
you're you're the lead back there uh
when
healthy what was that like for you this
year that again melvin gordon as we know
was holding out last year and you
stepped in
and you definitely made more of a name
for yourself and this was going to be
your year to be
the man and then your hamstring damn
near rips off the bone right was it that
bad
for you austin yeah uh yeah going into
week four you know i was
having pretty good outings like i said
being efficient uh
coming into years i was like 130 40
yards a game
so you know i was out here playing well
we were so shy you know that's a
different story
but yeah week four i injured my
hamstring
and i had torn like the muscle on my
hamstring and then torn the tendon off
the bone a little bit so
pretty significant injury there's a
higher hamstring usually get like a
lower hamstring injury but mine was
really high because i was just an
awkward position what happened
and yeah that basically took me out for
two months and you know
in the nfl there's not really a lot of
time to be sitting out
so i missed a lot of games like six or
seven
and definitely you know the team's been
struggling so it doesn't help when
you know we've had some other guys
injured as well but finally made it back
i've gotten a couple games under my
under my belt and now i'm feeling more
so like myself
uh so looking forward to being out in
these last three games
um taking it one at a time though with
the raiders coming up on thursday yeah
and i appreciate you joining me here in
a short week and we'll talk about your
gridiron gaming group in a second
austin eckler here on the rich eisen
show your coach is on a hot seat sir
i i you know i'm i'm sure you're aware
of that um
what what what does a locker room think
when when you hear that
that anthony lynn is on the hot seat
what does that
bring in your i feel like because
to me my perspective is like look this
is the nfl team like people are gonna
win people are gonna lose
and it's like people always try to okay
figure out what's the reason we're
losing
and they try to pinpoint it but however
like when it comes to
the nfl and playing football it's the
ultimate team sport um so
it's usually not ever anyone's fault
directly if it is it's
usually pretty obvious and i just i just
don't see that being the situation out
here you know there's
times where it's been like okay coaching
decisions we messed up so maybe that's
why you know the media is like trying to
pinpoint that
or there's been times when the offense
did not play well when we usually played
well for instance when we lost 45 to
zero
like this is the nfl like you know we
didn't score an entire point the entire
game like sure
coaching could have been better but
offensively we have to make plays and
put points on the board
and so i just think it's it's too hard
to justify to say
it's because of anthony lane and he's on
the hot seat because of that so
uh i get his role his role is to
represent our team so i get that's why
the media is kind of you know
pushing towards that point um but
collectively we're in this together hey
we got three more games we're gonna try
to win all these
come down the back stretch and it's up
to us to try to be as consistent as we
can as a team and you know specifically
uh
me on the offense um just trying to you
know carry my load
and what's expected what's expected of
me in this offense and help
and they're all divisions they're all
division games too austin i mean that
that that's a nice
measuring stick too for you to finish up
here and finish up strong
uh how good is justin herbert how good
is this kid
so far man he's shown the potential that
he's going to be a great player
uh you know i see his arm strength and
his arm talent um when he's running
getting hit
um just in all sorts of different
situations you know long throw short
throws just decision making has been
getting better with experience as far as
changing plays as far as column
protections to protect himself from
blitz
and you know i think he's going to be
really special he's a really smart kid
really dedicated
he has good team chemistry which is very
important
you know his competitor uh and so just
having him in the room i don't know it
just
he still seems like he's the rookie as
far as like the chemistry but
like i said that'll come with time um
especially coming into a room we know
with a lot of older guys
uh i think he's like one of the youngest
on the team too so i'm really looking
forward to
playing with him over the next couple
years and seeing him develop well he
clearly made a rookie mistake letting
john lott cut his hair
uh that's that was uh
how much of grief did the team give him
well you know we gave a little crap but
at the end of the day you know
it's all funny games like of course you
stuck with it so
so yeah no we definitely uh gained some
getting some heck for that i mean
yeah i mean let john lot of all people
your strength and conditioning coach
i mean i don't look at john and say and
say he's a stylist in any way shape or
form right you know i mean
you're the first round pick you can
afford to have someone come cut your
hair in los angeles
i mean in l.a my god there's like a
thousand people that would do that
better than just they'll even come to
your house so you don't have to worry
about getting course
of course you do it in the backyard i
mean it's not it's 70 degrees i mean
what's he thinking
what the hell was that honestly he's
just i i don't know trying to build some
chemistry i guess like i said
austin eckler here on the rich eisen
show okay sir the gridiron
gaming group right um you're
you're you're definitely one of the most
famous gamers in the national football
league is anybody who's even twitched
towards twitch would know
what's gridiron gaming group what is it
right so before i go i just want to
kind of get the misconception that i'm
like a gamer because twitch is a
live streaming platform not just a
gaming platform
okay i do do some gaming on there but
for the most part it's just me
uh have an opportunity to interact with
whoever wants to stop by
asking questions talk about live
football funny things that's going on
um it's more just a of an interactive
thing that i started when cove would
really hit and we can't have any like
signings or giveaways
right and so i started looking to twitch
to live stream and you know talk to
people
and then you know i kind of had a proof
of concept with myself and just
seeing all these different opportunities
that doing live streams brought to me
and so then i went ahead and formed a
team and joined
and created what's called a gridiron
gaming group
and basically what gridiron gaming group
is long story short it's just
a platform um to bring other athletes
other influencers that want to be in the
space
uh bring them to this platform so they
don't have to start from ground zero
they can start with
already you know my editor's help they
can start with uh
our sponsors of gridiron gaming group
and then it's an opportunity for
sponsors to also get involved to have
their
products in a new and a new space for
example you know i've done some
fundraisers
um i've done some just actual like
just promotion events like samsung
um wilson's one of our sponsors and so
we just have a lot of new people getting
involved because this is a new space
especially when we're at home so much
people are looking for new ways to do
like see content create content
and yeah i'm reaching out to any uh
athletes
influencers that want to try to come
join a group and we can bounce you know
uh our platforms off each other and grow
together and
gain traction and open up opportunities
for ourselves okay
so uh should i bring my vcr with me
austin if i come yeah bring it in
bring my vcr my dvds and my my walkman
right should i bring all that my record
player
for sure but yeah if you want to come
check me out on twitch yeah it's
awesomeneckler on twitch
okay uh i stream on tuesdays and fridays
yeah and then so who's gonna co-host
thursday night football
uh if you're actually playing in boston
what about that another thing i've been
doing
yeah and that's that's another
opportunity that i've had uh
is partnering with twitch in the nfl and
streaming the thursday night football
games and so i would have never had that
opportunity
hadn't been for twitch so right uh but
who said
that but this week you know who's
sitting thinking about putting my laptop
on the sidelines and going over and
talking when the defense is on the field
but like
i pay attention yeah i don't know if
coach lin i don't know if coach lynn
would give
the the the blue check mark to that one
uh the powder blue check mark would not
come for that one
austin so we'll just have to do without
a thursday night with austin eckler
on twitch but uh hey look
congratulations on everything that
you're doing i mean that is
that is uh a great use of the platform
that you have
and the moments that you have uh being a
national football league player
uh that uh uh of your
your style and your grace as well as
your your your playing acumen this is
this is beyond beyond wise and uh way to
go
is what i'm saying hey thank you [ __ ] i
appreciate that you got it you got it
just well just
uh because again you know i know uh you
don't want to be known as a gamer
that's that said right that said okay i
will just say this
that said are you the best at it in the
nfl when you do it
are you the best at yes i would say i'm
the best streamer yes
okay you're the best streamer on twitch
okay
uh you know and i need and i need to
basically say this then too austin
um you know since i did say the words
dvd before which made you
laugh um you're on a streamer right now
on peacock so
i get it it's basically what i'm saying
i understand
yeah there you go there you go streaming
we can relate
we can relate see we finally came all
together last one for you austin
uh did lamar jackson go to the bathroom
last night what do you think
what do you think as a professional
football player
who knows it and sees it and understands
it what do you think what do you think
what do you think i'm gonna say i'm
gonna say no i'm gonna believe him that
he ate some crabs
now you you did you ever play in the old
did you play in the old uh
qualcomm did you close down qualcomm
were you there i did not i was only up
in the uh
okay because i was talking there used to
be a bathroom right on the sideline for
the chargers so that wouldn't happen
so okay so you're going to okay so
you're going you're going lamar did in
fact take the iv
last night yeah for sure for sure is
that because you're a nice guy is that
what you're saying or what
come on now what do you think i mean i
just it makes sense
like if you had to go to the bathroom i
wouldn't just say you had to go to the
bathroom
okay there you go emergency austin
eckler it's happened we're only human
right it's basically what you're saying
we're only human right
well congrats again so tomorrow you're
going to be announcing the first nfl
team members
signing on to your gridiron gaming group
company correct that's happening
tomorrow yeah that'll be announced
tomorrow i believe yeah on twitch
on twitch is that what you're doing uh i
think my well my twitch stream already
knows probably about it but
officially to the world okay very good
on other socials
thank you very much austin we'll we'll
be looking out for that let's do this
more often thanks for the call
awesome let's do it thanks richard you
got it that's austin eckler at austin
eckler on both
twitter and instagram hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here